August hasn't been in class
since last October.
We need him in class.
It's a budget thing.
Are you gonna make sure my son
doesn't get shot walkin' home from school?
Is that your son in there
making music right now?
You know who I am?
Security guard at my school.
I mean, yeah I am but I'm also a manager.
I'm gonna help you with your music.
Oh, that's it right there.
He's a machine that makes a beat a minute.
He's fragile.
-Come on, what's her name?
-Naya.
Hey, Naya!
You just gonna hit her with your creepy
window game or ya'll talkin'?
I'm gettin' back in the game.
The kid is a way back in.
August needs therapy!
He hasn't been right
since his sister got shot.
What are you doing with my son?
Is Naya here?
I'm just here for moral support.
He can do big things in this world.
But he has to be in this world.
I will make you...
the most famous 17-year-old in Rose Lane.
How do we do those type of things?
My son was very happy before
you started coming around here.
I just wanna be normal!
People that listen to your music
wanna be free.
Make some noise!
This Chicago!
My brothers is dead
and I'm standin' here!
I told you not to get in his head!
Mom!
Now let's make some music.